[Music]
so here we are with american rapper
logic with such a logical chess name how
happened
yeah that's uh i probably should have
shaved before this interview
yeah but i mean when i heard
i mean that you're here i mean it's it's
a very big
honor for our events to have you here so
welcome to single hub how was it going
did you like it um yeah i absolutely
loved it here it was amazing i'm sorry
for the sound in the background i've
always wanted to come here and my good
friend joe bruin he invited me today him
and uh and danny wrench and yeah i got
to see some of the greatest players ever
to do it
in their element so yeah yeah and who's
your actual favorite player who am i
rooting for
i mean we all love magnus right
but also
i don't know man ollie's great and you
gotta love bobby so it's like those
three like i want to see what happens i
don't know i know that's like a weird
answer but i love magnus but i also love
those other guys too so that's for sure
how was the plane haul i mean did you
enjoy watching the game so close
yeah that was really
amazing and then even beforehand being
able to like play a couple games myself
um here at chess club it was really
special actually it doesn't happen every
day that you i mean you play with the
hockey player chess i mean robert thomas
was here as well yeah and how how was it
won at the end he was a real gentleman
and um but i took him two games
that's cool i know that you are going to
have a concert i think today so
i'm looking forward
yes i can't wait for the show tonight i
think it's going to be amazing thousands
of people are going to be there and
we're going to have a blast yeah thank
you so much will you invite us to the
players of course everybody can come
thank you all the best of luck on the
show thank you very
[Music]
much you